depuis toujours dans l'économie l'une
des valeurs refuges et d'investir dans
la pierre dans notre pays 58% des
français sont propriétaires de leur toit
une population parmi laquelle de
nombreuses personnes se demandent
comment la crise du coronavirus va
aujourd'hui impacté la valeur de leur
bien car s'il est évident qu'une crise
économique va suivre la crise sanitaire
que nous connaissons il est encore
difficile d'en estimer son ampleur deux
scénarios semblent s'offrir aux
professionnels du secteur
le premier très optimistes tablent sur
une reprise progressive de l'activité et
un retour à la normale d'ici décembre
2020 pour les autres les choses
pourraient se compliquer dans le cas où
le pays connaîtrait un krach financier
dans le second scénario la valeur des
biens pourrait s'effondrer un
effondrement qui pourrait
particulièrement touché les grandes
villes car on prédit une tendance du
retour de nombreux citadins vers la
campagne après cette crise une
désertification qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences importantes en saturant les
marchés de la vente dans les grandes
villes et ainsi faire plonger les prix à
la baisse face à cette situation inédite
plusieurs économistes proposent une
solution un impôt sur la fortune à
l'échelle européenne un impôt qui ne
concernerait que les 1% les plus riches
de france qui ne serait appliquée que
temporairement de leur côté les agents
immobiliers s'apprête à reprendre
progressivement le chemin du travail
comme le précise jean-marc toro lyon le
président de la fnaim nous allons
organiser une sortie progressive du
chômage partiel le télétravail sera
prolongée et il y aura sans doute une
rotation des salariés en agence reste à
voir quel scénario s'applique pas
réellement après le 11 mai alors gilles
verdez eric girard alors le sujet est
très bien fait il ya une grosse
inquiétude c'est les banques
vous savez que là les banques se portent
en quelque sorte caution notamment pour
les commerces donc les banques font le
maximum mais voilà et donc est ce que
les banques
est ce que les banques vont avoir des
conditions plus restrictives pour
l'accès au crédit liés à l'immobilier
très sûrement donc notamment les jeunes
ménages qui vont vouloir investir et
bien ils auront plus de mal pour se
faire prêter
donc ça veut dire que le marché peut
être très très impactées par ça et
deuxième rangs il ya une info qui est
très intéressant c'est que par rapport à
l'habitat il ya le boom notamment qui va
faire monter les prix le groupe des
résidences de campagne parce que les
gens se disent qu un confinement on peut
en avoir une autre choix et les gens
vont vouloir investir à la campagne bah
oui mais bon il faudrait déjà il faut
des il faut avoir de l'oseille un pur
avec la campagne plus sa résidence
principale
frérot je suis pas sûr là je suis pas
sûr de ce que tu dis excuse moi je
t'aime beaucoup hein mais bon voilà je
suis pas sûr oui laurent seigne
moi je pense que déjà on vide les loyers
vont baisser parce qu'il y aura plus
d'airbnb dans les grandes villes
parce que pendant quelques mois y en
aura plus donc j'imagine que les
propriétaires vont peut-être revenir à
la raison ce que leur fera du bien parce
que par exemple à paris c'est
complètement délirant mais surtout ce
qui a été tancé pour les propriétaires
qui sont des retraités qui ont économisé
toute leur vie pour avoir un outil bien
immobilier hélas si on a une chute de
l'immobilier là par contre ça peut être
vraiment une galère pour eux est ce que
vous savez quand vous avez comme vous et
votre maison à une famille en difficulté
vous n'allez pas là j'étais dehors quand
ça nous impacte aussi je pense que
derrière il va y avoir beaucoup beaucoup
de choses à revoir et ça va être
compliqué pour ce plan une fois de plus
alors juste il paraît que ça va être
bien de rien on province que voilà que
ça va le plus baissé dans certaines
régions voilà je crois qu'on a un
tableau récapitulatif à paris ça va un
peu moins baissé même on parle de -5%
voilà valérie benaïm oui mais c'est la
grande interrogation ce que disait
laurence effectivement c'est que il ya
beaucoup notamment de locataires qui
contactent leurs propriétaires en disant
est ce qu'on peut faire un report pour
le loyer est ce qu'on peut faire un
report est compris entre les syndiqués
déshabille pour les charges etc et donc
sylvain et tout le monde essaie de
d'arranger tout le monde mais à un
moment arrive en bout de pouce et quid
de ce bout de course comment ça va se
passer à ce moment là c'est là la vraie
interrogation c'est la première étude
alors les chiffres 20 % des français
veulent changer d'habitation
un français sur trois aimerait que son
bien se rapproche de la nature
voyez donc moi je pense que peut-être il
ya des gens qui vont essayer de vendre
en ville pour se rapprocher de la nature
mais je pense vraiment que l'achat de
résidences secondaires je suis pas sûr
que ça va exploser mon fils ou même si
j'aime pas de contredire mais il faut
déjà pouvoir être une résidence
principale plus avoir en plus une
résidence secondaire ça me semble
compliqué surtout après la crise du
coronavirus 1 français sur 3 après avoir
un logement plus grand ça on peut le
comprendre
un français sur quatre aimerait à
présent disposer d'un espace extérieur
balcons terrasses jardins 17% des
français disent que ce n'est plus
essentiel d'avoir son bien à côté de son
travail
moi je pense qu'on a je pense que
peut-être qu'il va y avoir
boum un bon voilà dans des dans des
régions voilà où dans des voiles ados
plus à la campagne a peut-être des gens
qui vont vivre toute l'année à la
campagne qui m'ont dit on va faire plus
de route ça nous dérange pas à la nuit
de toutes les façons je vais vous dire
c'est dans paris intra muros que ça
roule le plus mal et bien sûr ça va
continuer puisque apparemment anne
hidalgo sa va repasser
donc ça ne changera pas donc voilà dans
à paris intra muros bien entendu ce sera
un pari ça s'appelle plus à paris intra
muros à ça s'appelle paris cintra
travaux ce pays et que des travaux ce we
benjamin castaldi
écoutez moi je crois que j'ai dénoncée
moi je vous ai appelé par votre nom
c'est le forcené non je vous en prie non
je pense que malheureusement je vais
encore peut-être choquer mais je pense
qu'effectivement c'est une puce les
biens de qualité avec des terrasses avec
des espaces extérieurs qui vont
effectivement le mieux s'en sortir et
c'est ce qu'ils ont pas forcément htc
c'est bien là qui vont prendre là qui
vont payer la note
voilà ce que je pense et les petits
bancs mais effectivement j'ai entendu
comme gilles que beaucoup de gens
voulaient changer et se rapprocher de la
nature est effectivement avoir un petit
espace extérieur donc scellé c'est ce
qu'on appelle les billes à un peu un peu
supérieurs qu'ils vont garder voire
prendre de la valeur donc c'est encore
les mêmes qui vont trinquer d'accord
jean-michel mais oui nous nous c'est
vrai qu'on a pas tellement chose qu'on a
un travail qui nous obligeait à paris
voilà
mais c'est vrai que si ce n'était pas le
cas moi je sais que la crise en tout cas
m'a amené à réfléchir un peu sur le les
valeurs essentielles sur la famille sur
le châssis sont essentielles et du
couche
j'aurais bien aimé c'est bref allez
peut-être pas tant d'endroits où la vie
est plus calme ou avec ma famille où on
se recentre sur les choses essentielles
et puis être toujours dans la course
parisienne j'aurais aimé c'est pas
possible c'est vrai que moi ça m'a amené
à l'accession
alors viens vous dire ce qui pose
problème aussi même si la tentation
d'attendre pour investir plus tard et
plus fort il faut quand même faire
attention pour ceux qui veulent investir
puisque parce que les taux d'intérêt
pourraient exploser pour les français ce
matin et non plus une enquête très
pessimiste du parisien est sorti sur le
rapport des français avec le taux
d'emprunt
il explique 220 mille foyers seront
privés d'accès à l'emprunt
c'est énorme les foyers vivant en ville
seront les plus impactées et un recul de
36% de production de crédits prévus pour
voilà donc c'est vrai que
voilà on va avoir moi je pense un gel de
l'immobilier de rien parce que je vois
pas les gens
je vous dire il ya moi j'ai plein de
potes aussi dans l'immobilier qui me dit
j'avais plein de transactions qui
étaient en train de se faire avant le
courant n'a et maintenant les gens ont
peur aussi et banias des gros salaires
mine de rien et des mecs qui ont des
gros postes dans des entreprises qui
disaient que mon ordi crise va pouvoir
voilà père et se pérenniser va pouvoir
continuer à faire cette procès à ses
productions
donc forcément j'annule parce
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai pas j'ai pas je n'ai
pas l'assurance de pouvoir continuer à
travailler dans cette entreprise donc
pendant des mois je pense qu'il va avoir
les produits y va pour être jolie oui
jean-michel lesire avec les banques leur
demande beaucoup d'efforts mais elles
ont déjà commencé à un peu des taux
commencent à augmenter à un rythme
encore emprunter un achat immobilier par
exemple les taux qui est abondée par 3 à
maintenant ils sont déjà passés à 06 07
ça commence déjà augmenté ça va aller ça
l'avait de façon exponentielle session
sophie costard qu'on aura la version à
la conclusion du forcené
non mais c'est ça c'est certain comme
disait jean michel on est tous en train
de réfléchir à une autre façon de vivre
et surtout on est tous en train de se
dire et si on se reprend à 1 2e
confinement derrière d'ici quelques mois
comment est-ce qu'on aurait envie de le
vivre jusque là pour le coup on est un
peu préparé mentalement et on dit est ce
qu'on a envie de revivre la même chose
le problème c'est que ok on a envie nous
peut-être parisien où les gens qui
habitent dans les grandes villes de se
rapprocher de la campagne encore faut-il
pouvoir louer son bien ou vendre son
bien
qui va pouvoir l'acheter aujourd'hui
comme vous dites ça va être gelée donc
est ce qu'on va pouvoir se déplacer je
suis pas certaine alors s'il vous plaît
benjamin castadi le forcené
votre conclusion la suite mais justement
benjamin castadi après la question que
vous poserez pour pouvoir peut-être
acheté peut-être faire bouger
l'immobilier est ce que certains patrons
vont devoir baisser leur salaire
[Musique]
on peut aussi voir les choses de façon
pleine et c'est à dire que cette crise
peut-être date est aussi réajuster le
prêt immobilier que les jambes de
vouloir accéder aussi plus facilement on
peut aussi c'est devant les choses
positivement vous êtes sûrs a pas que
des effets négatifs aussi brève que je
peux vous dire